and for frankie montauk coming off an
outing which he punched out 11
guys that right there tells you he's
starting to feel it
tommy hits this one in the air toward
the left field corner pinder circling
around now stops running track and he
makes the catch
grounded in the hole sanders backhands
and throws out anthony rendon and that's
a three-up three-down inning for
frankie montauk
on the mound for the angels alex cobb
last time around
was in game one of that may 20th
doubleheader against the twins threw the
ball very well did not
walk a batter went 5-1 run innings
[Applause]
got him
[Applause]
and he freezes tony kemp back-to-back
strikeouts open the afternoon for alex
cobb
we were told game time temperature was
59 degrees
doesn't bother the banana group though
in fact guys if i remember correctly
last night there was three bananas
today there's four bananas they went
shopping
to the bushel so they added a banana
yeah well between last night and tonight
they keep hydrating i imagine they'll be
peeling layers
into the opposite field and well hit
pender can't make the catch it's off the
wall
and jared wheels into second with a
leadoff double
long a left-handed hitter
and he bumps it right back to frankie
montas under hands to first and that'll
do it
so walsh with a lead off double he does
not score
[Applause]
that chapman waits on deck here's the
3-2 payoff pitch
and he got him to chase that splitter
and he struck him
out swinging first pitch to ben boomi
slams it to right center field
on the run kat is still going still
going dives he's got it
what a catch by kenna sprinting toward
right
center field leaving his feet and
robbing bem boom in his return
to the big leagues of a double
spectacular defense
continues this weekend at the coliseum
heard some cheering going on right below
us
i think that's why oh that's awesome
lefty
and he is pumped
andrews stays put ground ball to third
rendone to second for one longs relay
they get them both
tiny swings and missy waved at it that's
the first strikeout for frankie montas
stayed for the split
lines of first pitch into the gap in
left center field brendon around first
on his way into second
with a one out doubled in the angels
half of the fourth
yeah that's a swing and a miss garcia
long throw
in time
so random goes to third two outs
[Applause]
and that is a swing and a miss 96 miles
an hour
here's olson
[Applause]
green light on 3-0 and a high fly ball
into a
vacated cavernous part of the ballpark
and rendon gets there for the out
kemp advances and then he over slides at
second base
i don't know if tony kemp thought that
ball had gotten away from fletcher
or if his pop-up slide just took him off
the bag either way
it turns into a very unlikely
five to six double play
dancing around at second is rojas in the
pitch is a high fastball and he got it
the wong chased upstairs
[Applause]
another splitter that one caught a lot
of the strike zone and it's into right
field to base hit
rojas to third
and for the first time in this game the
angels have multiple base runners aboard
big opportunity now for david fletcher
who lined a left in his first at-bat
today
0-1 to david fletcher
bunting olson comes home it's mishandled
in the angels score
wow boy do the halos catch a break there
and he's out by a bunch rojas is
he flips it right to garcia who was
looking at the runner to look the ball
into his glove
what a break
so he's looking to see where rojas is at
he didn't look it into the glove a huge
break because he's going to be out by
quite a bit
he's almost as if he was going to try to
get into a rundown to get both the
runners
in the scoring position
safety squeeze here's shohei at the
plate with two outs and two on angel's
trying to add on
1-0 to ohtani into left field to base
hit that's going to score ben boom
easily fletcher comes around to score
three-nothing angels
the batter will be anthony rendon
2-2 to rendon is shot into right field
brown up and throwing
ohtani being waved around no play at the
plate four-nothing angels
pinder the hitter with runners at first
and second and nobody out
pinder sends a double play ball to the
infield and the angels convert that one
to god that's the beauty of a guy that
gets a lot of ground balls
owen to the count to elvis andrews
[Applause]
got him to chase five strikeouts for
cobb nothing comes to the walk-in
single that opened the inning and it's
still four-nothing angels
[Music]
swinging a miss by garcia and that's six
for cobb today
he's ready trying to get the final out
the 2-2 delivery
and he got him struck him out the inning
is over boy kemp was right on top of the
plate there
110 miles an hour back up the middle
maybe that's why we like to swing at the
bat
wow that ball's flat on one side now
here's the next delivery and that one is
chased and missed and down
on strikes goes chapman and that is how
the
inning will end that could be it for
alex cobb if it is
seven shutout innings hard to complain
about that
job well done by alex cove he pitched
seven
scoreless innings gave up only three
hits
walk two struck out eight
owen one to kemp and that should do it
rysel iglesias puts the finishing
touches on the angels first
shutout win of 2021.